hey guys
welcome back to my youtube channel uh i
have some great news
there's a new instrument which i will be
adding to my
sort of arsenal of all things that go
pluck
and i think you're really gonna like
this one
so here we have the baroque loot
it's a
absolutely beautiful
looking instrument
this is the back here that is made up of
individual strips of wood we call ribs
in this case the wood is made out of
this gorgeous
orangey reddish flame maple
and the top is made of spruce with this
gorgeous
decoration here called a rose
the baroque loot gets its name from
existing in the baroque period of music
which is roughly 1600 to 1750.
it was popular all throughout europe
but really blossomed in france
now the instrument has 24 strings which
is a lot even for me
the fiorbo for as a point of reference
only has 14.
now although it's true that there are 24
when this is played it's really thought
of as a 13
string instrument
and that's because each string is
doubled we call them courses so there's
13 pairs of strings
and the top two are
are single
those are called the chanterelle or the
the singing strings
this specific loot was made by the
french company lelout dore or the golden
loot they're a company that makes
great quality loots for a more
affordable affordable price
and
if you're a classical guitarist and
don't want to break the bank but are
interested in learning renaissance loot
or baroque loot
this would be a great company to
start learning
now the tuning of this instrument is
part of what makes it so special
most guitars or loots are tuned in
fourths
and it requires you to use your left
hand to
fret notes to make a chord
this instrument is tuned to a chord so
if i play the open strings
we get a beautiful sounding d minor
chord and that really opens up all sorts
of new possibilities of left-hand
fingerings um because it frees up the
left hand uh in a new way allowing for
new possibilities
so the the d minor chord is really on
the first
half of the instrument
and the rest of the strings are tuned in
a descending scale which is actually
exactly what the
what the fierbo does
as well
so from a we get g
b f
d c in this case i have b flat
and a
those those notes can be
rearranged depending on the key of the
music you're playing in
this peg box is so intimidating to look
at
with 24
different friction pegs so there are no
no mechanical gears those didn't exist
until the 19th century these are
essentially like violin picks they just
they're just held in with friction
now there's some alien looking parts to
this that that's that are new to me
actually
we have this extension here
called a base rider and you can see that
the first nut stops here and the second
extra one that has two courses
gives it an extra i don't know inch or
inch and a half or maybe two inches
and that extra length actually is great
for giving the base a bit more
so i've only had a few hours since i've
got this thing in tune to start picking
away at some music since this is all
brand new to me
um but i think i've figured out the
opening of a vice star bond that i used
to play on guitar
so
i'll take a crack at it
[Music]
so
[Music]
whoa
i'm sort of blown away by
um
how this instrument feels to play uh
it's bizarre because since i know this
piece on guitar
and i'm now playing it on the instrument
for which it was written
it's so much easier on this instrument
even though i've put in my 10 000 hours
on guitar and this is my third hour or
so playing this instrument um one of the
reasons has to be because this is a d
minor suite a piece in d minor and the
instrument
is tuned to d minor
i think another thing that changes the
game is that because i have all of these
open notes
in the bass
i don't have to spend so much time in my
left hand fingering those and trying to
play a nice legato melodic line
they're just open played by my thumb
which is really similar to what i do on
fiorbo as well
besides that
i think the the lower tension strings
in fact they're very low i can really
wiggle these around um on a classical
guitar they're very very tight very high
tension
the low tension strings on this really
makes ornaments
so easy and effortless you get a sound
a sound which is uh more equal between
the pluck and the slur
and i think that really helps
helps the melody along now the notation
for
this instrument is
french tablature uh tab right so if
you're a modern guitar player tab is
when you have lines representing strings
and numbers for which fret play this is
pretty much the same thing
except it uses letters for each fret so
a b c d e f g etc and the music is
absolutely beautiful to look at
there's this incredible aesthetic
experience of playing from a facsimile
which is a picture of the manuscript the
original
handwriting of vice
it's beautiful to look at and so i'm
just loving
sight reading through this music
it's a it's a joy
[Music]
i'm absolutely in love with this
instrument
the tuning the extra bass strings
it's going to take me a lot of time to
figure this thing out but thank you for
listening today as i
learn about this instrument
tune back in because i'm going to be
posting more videos
as i get better on this instrument and
you can come learn it with me so thanks
for watching and come back for more
later